hey guys it's Jonah here so let's get
straight into it what is a fermentation
fermentation is one of the oldest forms
of food preservation
so fermenter food goes through the
process in which natural bacteria fits
on sugar and starch and creates lactic
acid where vegetables like cabbage and
cucumbers are left to steep and sit
until the sugars are broken down to
provide a group of bacteria that is when
vegetables are fermented fermentation
preserves vegetables raw and without
heat so it retains all its vitamins
nutrients and also enzymes plus
fermentation of vegetables will also
enhance the nutrients in it why then do
I consume fermented vegetables and not
wrong let me just start by saying that
there are lots of health benefits when
it comes to eating raw vegetables but if
you find that consuming raw vegetables
causes indigestion and bloating then
you're just like me now it is true that
cooking slightly will destroy a little
bit of the nutrients but that's only ten
percent you still have the remaining 90%
for your body to absorb the Chinese
believes that whatever you put into your
body that is raw and cold your body
needs to heat and cook it takes time
energy and slows down the metabolism
hence cooking your vegetables slightly
helps to lighten the load and it makes
it easier for your body to digest so I
do consume a little bit of raw
vegetables especially green leafy
vegetables but I prefer cooked and
fermented vegetables because it makes it
easier for my body to digest fermented
vegetables make nutrients more easily
available they promote a healthy gut and
contains probiotics since 70 to 80
percent of the immune system lies in the
cart having a healthy gut is extremely
important and it can either help with
weight loss the question is can you
consume too much fermented food yes it
is possible to consume too much of a
good thing so you were to consume often
rather than in large quantities here's a
guideline to begin with consume
have a cup of your favorite fermented
vegetables or two ounces of your
favorite fermented liquid
now if fermented foods are completely
new to your system you may experience
some mild to moderate symptoms which is
completely natural and healthy for your
body this include gas breakout headaches
and more but don't worry
nothing wrong is happening guys in fact
only the good things are happening
because your body is getting rid of
toxins so give your body time to adjust
and also adapt the ferment of food are
replacing those toxins with beneficial
life enhancing bacteria which will
eventually make you feel and look good
so as your body slowly adjust you can
add one more additional serving so add
another half a cup of fermented
vegetables or 2 ounces of your favorite
fermented liquid into two of your meals
in a day again
moderation is key to good health ok you
don't have to spend lots of money on
fermented foods or drinks in fact you
can make them at home it is really
simple it requires very little
ingredients but a lot of patience so I'm
gonna share with you three fermented
vegetables to get you started let's
start with a sauerkraut only two
ingredients 3 pounds of green cabbage
shredded and about one and a half
tablespoons of pink Himalayan salt
simply combined at the cabbage and salt
begin working the salt into the cabbage
by massaging and squeezing the cabbage
with your hands until the cabbage is
watery and limp this will take about
five to ten minutes so be patient and
work of those biceps then grab handfuls
of the cabbage and pack them into your
just pour any liquid released by the
cabbage into the jar then place one of
the larger outer leaves of the cabbage
over the surface to cover the strata
cabbage to where the cabbage down slip
in a smaller jar weighted with stones or
pebbles you want to make sure that the
cabbage is fully submerged beneath its
liquid cover the mouth of the jar with a
cloth to make sure its air
Heights then allow the cabbage to
ferment for three to ten days keeping
the sauerkraut away from direct sunlight
and at a cool room temperature this
sauerkraut is a fermented product so it
will keep for at least two months and
longer if it's kept in the fridge the
next recipe is Japanese pickled cucumber
what I've used are three Japanese
cucumbers thinly sliced two teaspoons of
salt quarter cup of rice vinegar 2
tablespoons of brown sugar and two
tablespoons of sesame seeds in a bowl
add the cucumber and sprinkle with the
salt mix well set aside for about 5
minutes and drain the liquid combine all
the ingredients rice vinegar brown sugar
sesame seeds mix well transfer into an
airtight jar and let it sit in the
fridge for at least 24 hours and it's
ready to be eaten this recipe is so
simple and it goes perfectly with rice
and the final recipe is pickled cabbage
and carrots so what you'll need are 3
cups of red cabbage shredded 1 cup of
carrot thinly sliced 1 cup of rice
vinegar 3/4 cup of brown sugar half a
teaspoon of sesame oil 2 teaspoons of
salt and a pinch of hot chili flakes in
a large bowl toss the cabbage together
with the carrots set aside in a saucepan
over medium heat stir together the
vinegar sugar sesame oil chili flakes
and salt mix until sugar has dissolved
for about 3 minutes then allow the sauce
mixture to cool down pour it over the
cabbage and carrot mixture and toss well
cover and chill in the fridge for at
least 8 hours or overnight the next day
transfer the pickled mixture into an
airtight jar all these recipes will keep
for a long time in the fridge so you can
make a huge batch and consume one to two
servings a day
missile kombucha tempeh soil kimchi and
kefir are some other fermented foods you
can also start to add into your diet so
try all these recipes out and start to
add more fermented food into your diet
you can start with one serving and
slowly increase it to two servings if
you enjoyed this video if you find this
video to be helpful be sure to give it a
thumbs up share with your friends and
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more fitness videos workout videos
recipes and also tips guys do hit and
turn on your notification button so that
you would get notified every time I
share a new video all the best